these two family members are moaning the
loss of their son and husband and Kenya
samburu County
Michael Karam was hurting his family's
livestock when cattle Bandits raided a
water points he and the neighbor was
shot dead
I blame the bandits my husband would not
have died if it was not for the bullet
from them I also blame the government
because it has failed to keep us safe
a short distance away another victim
shows us an animal Shed from where armed
men took dozens of cows and goats
when the bandits came I ran away I slept
in a neighboring Village I didn't know
where my children were I thank God they
are now safe
these are not isolated incidents almost
everyone in hurting communities along
the North reefed Valley has been
affected by banditry security officials
say more than 200 people including
police officers have been killed Since
2021. cattle rustling has long been a
problem in Kenya the government has
struggled to deal with it for many years
foreign
in some areas Security Forces including
the military are searching for Bandits
said to be hiding in caves gorges and
escapments deep in the valley a Dusk to
Dawn coffee is in place people in dozens
of villages have been told to vacate
their homes until the authorities finish
their job this is one of the areas where
people have been forced to leave some of
them are heading to other Villages
carrying with them whatever they can
they say they're not sure when they're
coming back home
this man says he is heading to an urban
town several kilometers from here
some of our neighbors including an area
Chief have been killed we've been
attacked very close to our home
back at Le karam's Village the hardest
return from grazing but a day after Al
Jazeera filmed there this heart of 80
cows was stolen Catherine soy Al Jazeera
samburu County